so I want to thank the organizers for
inviting me to this workshop I'm going
to talk today about diffusion based
metrics a perfect for biological network
analysis and in this workshop of course
we're going to be seeing a lot of
pictures like this and the problem that
I want to talk about attacking today is
the issue that comes from the fact that
many of these networks are so-called
small world networks probably a lot of
the people this audience would like to
approval with me about the definition of
small world network I see we have some
experts here who have studied various
small world properties of the network
like this hash and and tatiana here but
we want to worry about when everything
is nearby then it's very hard to define
an issue of a local neighborhood in a
network and this comes up even in things
like classical function predictions so
I'm back like Trey in the yeast world
where perhaps I have proteins of unknown
function other proteins are labeled by
an ontology maybe go maybe mips maybe
trays ontology and I am trying to maybe
assign labels to proteins well what a
lot of people have said it's well let's
look in the local neighborhood of a
protein let's see what the labels are of
proteins that are close by maybe that
will allow us to infer something about
the label of my protein and and the
problem with that is that everything is
close by so if we look at a histogram of
shortest path distances in yeast this is
again baker's yeast and maybe the data
is about a year old or so but um if you
look at the shortest path distances
almost everything is distance to or
through your part okay so if I want to
look at my neighbors my neighbors
neighbors very soon I get the whole
network
and what's going to rescue me from
getting confusion is that I claim that
not all short paths are equally strong
indications of similarity and to explain
that I'm going to given in analogy from
social networks so um so uh I think
there are a bunch of people whose
pictures on this slide you might
recognize um so um you guys know who
this is Donna salona she's sitting
shooting right there and mona singh is
not here yet but she's also a
co-organizer of this workshop and you
know clearly I know both of these
colleagues quite well and however triad
occur who gave the talk this morning I'd
actually never met in person until today
however i'm betting quite strongly that
he probably also knows mona singh and
donna slonim so if we kind of are
connected by a length two paths in say
social network of our friends then um
with them we'll probably have something
in common right we probably a lot of
short pass through fairly low degree
nodes um probably we have something in
common but on the other hand how many
people know who this is by the way
anybody who is that that's what P
Goldberg right so so she's she's a
famous comedian and movie star so if i
happen to be like Facebook friends or
fans with Whoopi Goldberg right and then
I look at all the other millions of
people in the world who are friends with
Whoopi Goldberg um probably we don't
have as much in common are you saying I
don't have a lot of friends
I'm saying that she doesn't know oh but
what I'm saying what I'm saying is is
that is that all right so maybe instead
of whoopi goldberg i should have put a
bianchi or the president of the united
states so so compared to them we don't
have a lot of friends or at least a lot
of people who would like to claim their
friends right so so somehow that if you
have a big high degree famous node in
the network and you look at last to pass
through that I claim that has less
similarity so this is a social network
maybe I should get away from these
dangerous analogies here because
actually it does tend to be the same in
biological networks if you look at the
things that are giant hubs in biological
networks they could be things like
chaperones okay they could be things
that are deal with the general machinery
of the cell and if you look at the
things that interact with them the
things that interact with them might be
interacting with them and they're not
very functionally similar maybe this is
something that you bring that degrades
proteins in the cell it's a vacuum
cleaner a lot of things are going to
interact with that they're not going to
have a lot of functionality things at
home so it would be nice to design some
kind of way to talk about similarities
these biological networks that kind of
takes us into account um so if we want a
more fine-grained measure of pairwise
similarity I claim we need a new
distance metric where recall I mean this
is the mathematical sense of a metric
which satisfy metric is something that
satisfies three properties if you
remember your linear algebra axioms you
only get 0 if and only if you're looking
to yourself but symmetric and it
satisfies a triangle inequality and once
we have it this this metric we could
look at the pairwise distance of all the
different pairs of nodes in the network
and this is that histogram again when i
look at shortest paths which is a
distance metric in the least network
just about everything is just as two or
three
okay so I'm gonna give you a definition
of a new that metric which i'm going to
call diffusion distance and i have this
picture up here which is also somebody
in the audience this is ben has scott
he's also talking about different stuff
on wednesday and everything i'm going to
talk about today just about except for
some of the new work i mentioned at the
end is all joy at work with ben has gone
so what do we do we define this h e
vector between a and B to be the
expected number of times the case step
random walks starting at a reaches be
okay so first thing I want you to know I
want to notice two things about this
first thing I want you to notice is that
this is kind of getting at something
that has the properties we bought so if
a and B are me and Trey okay then you're
very likely to get there in a short
random walk because we're joined by many
paths through low degree nodes so these
paths are likely to hit on the other
hand if it's me and I don't know
somebody else who likes Whoopi Goldberg
then these paths or knows not as likely
because if I go to the hub know then I'm
likely to diffuse away to another one of
its zillions and legions of neighbors so
pass through high degree nodes are less
likely to contribute to this value even
if they're the same length so that's
good but we're still not a metric yet
right and the reason we're not a metric
this is not even symmetric yet for
example if I'm in the center of this
flower um then for any particular petal
my probability of going there is para
lilo but if I'm at the pedal I'm always
going to go to the center right so this
is date so this is not even a symmetric
function yes so this is what i'm going
to do and there's a lot of math on the
slide but actually it's very intuitive
so let me walk you through it um so
again we're defining that a chief vector
between two nodes a and B for a
particular node a I'm now going to set
up a vector which is this H
value to all the other nodes in the
network so think of I'm taking a global
view of the whole graph it's like I'm
scattering breadcrumbs I'm looking at
for every other node how often I reach
that note and expected value okay and of
course i'm also getting considerably
like zero random walk so i always reach
myself and then what i'm going to do is
for any two nodes now i'm going to
define the diffusion state distance
between U and V to simply be the l1 norm
of the difference of those vectors in
other words what I'm going to do is for
every node where they look different in
this measurement I'm going to get a
little bit of contribution to their
dissimilarity and I'm gonna add those up
yes comment about this 01 normal because
it seems like that this is a mattress
only for even case no no no it's fine uh
in a bit but I I will I i do want to
continue I want to keep the zero
contribution because it's important for
proving that um it's only 0 when um the
nude is itself but it works okay yes
wait
yes is the you get the immediate
distance between the immediate neighbors
I connect the center of the panel is
opposed to on the left side a and one of
those are they all the same like is your
distance to Whoopi Goldberg the same as
your distance to what um not necessarily
know because I could go backwards this
is not directed okay so all right so um
in the paper we proved that DSD is a
metric and not only is it a metric but
it turns out it converges as K goes to
infinity so that might seem
counterintuitive the first time I write
down this definition that the length of
the random walk doesn't matter but let
me convince you so if you think about
this graph you can think about it's
mixing time there is some point of time
let's see that everybody is in disparate
points of this graph when we're all
exploring a city at some point we wander
around and we all reach the city center
and we you can't tell where we came from
anymore at that point our rest of our
random walk is making equal
contributions to these values so once
the warp mixes the rest of the duration
of the walk doesn't contribute to this
difference and that's why it converges
right so at some point the rest of that
so all the action is in the early steps
of the random walk
okay so it turns out that um you can
convert the uke so clearly if you're
doing up to particular case steps it's
easy to compute you can also compute the
converged CSD matrix and it's just an
eigenvalue computation so the complexity
is um dominated by the cost of inverting
finding the inverse of a matrix so if we
don't do anything terribly smart that's
going to be orange and in fact we have
code that implements okay and for those
of you who like matrix stuff there is a
deep connection it seems to the graph
laplacian and what we are doing this was
proved by Boland and now however they
took a different version where it's a
walk with restarts and they generalize
to the LP norm yes nice to see so-called
I can find eigenvalues and Charlotte is
that same concept so this is not a
centrality concept it's a dissimilarity
concept but these things are all related
okay so all this diffusion stuff is
extremely related and this seems
particularly related to something which
is called the greens function that was
first defined by fan Chung yes maybe too
early but that what is the advantage of
this metric over resistor distance I've
never studied resistor distance so i
don't know resistors distance may be
great but i will tell you why this
metric is good i I cannot compare it to
resistor distance okay um okay and
actually recently Andrew beverage who's
mathematician prove that this means that
DSD can be shown to measure the
difference between random walk starting
from U and V to a randomly chosen target
node D and maybe to answer your question
many other diffusion kernels and various
links have been proposed for ppi
networks and I put some of the
references up here about sort of other
measures that people have studied that
our diffusion based now most of them are
actually not a true distance metric
right so we actually get the triangle
inequality um maybe I'll convince you
later you should care okay so all right
so
I so I claim DSD is worthy of study it's
mathematically natural it's connected to
the graph laplacian its conversion
independent of the length of the random
walks and we have specifically designed
to down weight pass through Cubs okay so
so but we're not going to care unless we
can do something good in the
applications domain and this should
should intrigue you which is that when I
actually write down that histogram for
DST distance on the same network I get
this beautifully almost normal smooth
set of distances and the reason that's
really beautiful is that allows me to
talk about things like the closest
neighbor the second closest neighbor the
third closest neighbor right before I
had all these ties and now I have this
continuous measure of similarity that
again I'm going to show works if you
believe this business that things
through hubs look contribute last years
ok so again like Trey let's go to yeast
and sort of the very basic most studied
problems where there's the most data
let's look at classical function label
prediction um and so previously the
simplest classical method there is is
you could ask you could assign to a node
that is unknown the have all its
neighbors vote with their label or
multiple times with multiple labels and
assign the label that gets the highest
number of votes so we can do this with
DSP instead where we have the cake
closest DST neighbors vote
in fact we're not going to just do this
for this we're going to do this for four
different classical function prediction
methods we have sort of the normal
method and that I claim even if they
don't describe it this way at some level
is based on the shortest path distance
underlying it for determining similarity
in the network we're going to look at
majority vote neighborhood is a
generalized majority vote to distance
more than one multi-way cut method
functional flow method and then we're
going to look at a DSD version of these
problems where we somehow incorporate
the DSD distance instead alright so
let's and and here are some more
references for other people who have
made important contributions to
classical function prediction methods
I'm not going to talk about clustering
methods there's a wonderful survey of
Charan of all the work that was done to
date by 2007 I'm sure that it's been
double the number of papers since
because this is just a problem everyone
works okay so and what is the network
that i'm going to show you Rizzo
experimental results on i'm going to do
cross-validation on the yeast ppi
network and this is a bio grid version
of the network for now has about 5,000
no it's about 75,000 edges and we're
going to do 10 runs of twofold
cross-validation where we erase half the
labels and pretend they're unknown and
do prediction and we're going to report
Steve being in standard deviation thing
I want you to pay attention to his
accuracy where we're just going to write
us mark the percentage correct when we
assign each node its highest rank label
we also compute something called an f1
score which gets more into the sort of
precision recall trade-off ok so people
have talked about lots of ontologies but
no one has yet mentioned the mips fun
cat this is a vent ology that is really
only available for yeast but the nice
thing about it is it's a leveled
hierarchy it only has three levels and
on the top level there are 17 categories
that are things like cell cycle or DNA
the second level there's 74 category
things like DNA processing and then
maybe you're on the third level at ten
point 01 05 there's DNA repair any
combination there 154 categories on the
third level we also have results I go
that I will describe the problem with go
is of course it's a variable-length
hierarchy with lots of different lengths
paths there's a question of how you give
partial credit if you match an ancestor
of another term and you know their ways
people deal with that we'll discuss that
okay and and so here's a little piece of
the yeast interaction network and sort
of gets at the power of doing this if I
want to know the nodes and closest DSD
distance to geo r1 it turns out the
closest one is this mxr too and it turns
out to have the right functional label
the interesting thing about this is it's
not even a direct neighbor but it's the
closest ind EST distance because it has
the most common neighbors so DSD is
somehow getting at that notion okay so
majority vote is I just told you I'm
gonna have all my neighbors vote on my
label that's a classical method DST
majority vote I'm going to have the cake
closest neighbors where K is a parameter
and here are the results um if you
notice um the original majority vote is
doing about fifty percent on the top
level of the mix hierarchy and oh and
DST weighted versus DST unweighted see
these these ten or twelve closest
neighbors have different DST distance we
could have them vote equally or we can
have the vote in inverse proportion to
their DFT distance it turns out it
doesn't make a lot of difference having
them vote weighted improves things very
slightly so when we do that you see
there the probability shoots up above
sixty percent the minute we include a
bit about I don't know eight or nine ten
neighbors once we have at least ten
neighbors it kind of stabilizes out and
it's pretty robust so let's say we're
going to set k equal 10 for the
remainder of this chocolate just look at
ten neighbors and have them DST both
then we get similar approve myths on the
second and third level I'm running short
on time and I have a lot more slides so
I am
going to skip descriptions of some of
these other functional flow Mona sings
multi would cut but we have DSD versions
of all of these you can see them in the
paper and in summary in every single
case changing the metric to DSD improves
things and improves them remarkably
actually I was shocked sort of how much
we're dredging out of the hairball and
the best one ends up actually being
majority vote with weighted DST oh and
we have go results as well and if we're
going to do go results we want to worry
about this giving partial credit for
partially matching the go term at a
higher level of the hierarchy but the
percent improvement for all these
methods of counting is about the same
again DSD is always helping you and we
also did as Palm Bay just to do a sparse
or network and proportionally of course
if you have a sparse or network you're
not going to do as well but DST helps
you even more on sparse networks that a
dozen well annotated network so which is
good because we want to apply this skip
all this um okay I'm racing away here
all right thank you so much so how much
more time do I have do I have like ten
minutes five to seven okay so so far
diffusion metric was defined for
function prediction of biological
networks um and what I would one of the
things I want to say is that a lot of
people are like there's all this
diffusion stuff out there why DST and I
would say two things I would say this
whole class of methods is powerful but
part of the power comes and somehow
designing your thing to measure the
thing that lines up with whatever
biological property you care about in
this case I think the insight that we
want to download pass through hubs was
really important and therefore we came
up with a diffusion process that did
that if there's something else you're
trying to model in your network you want
to change your diffusion process and
model that so a good question is sort of
water the properties that really means
the molarity in these biological
networks and then and then we can try to
model them and this first paper was
published in PLoS ONE there's code you
can come up with something that computes
your DST matrix everything is publicly
available and the paper is freely
available okay so but eventually we
don't only want to do function
prediction we want to do the other thing
people tend to do when they walk around
these kinds of neckers which is disease
gene prioritization and give it a set of
cds known to be implicating some complex
disease we want to rank a set of other
genes is most related to the scene gene
set based on the people I network this
is also a very well study problem and
diffusion based methods are known again
to perform best um but so in order to
study DSD for Dezeen gene prioritization
um so DST gives a gene gene distance
several natural aids so you immediately
get a disease prioritization method if
you generalize DSC to a gene gene set
distance so you have a set of disease
genes you want your distance to them
that
finds some kind of order for disease
gene prioritization but before I do that
I have to deal somewhat with the human
network when I do with the human network
I'm going to be dealing with other kinds
of data because it's too sparse I'm
going to be dealing with co-expression
zeta very other kinds of data a lot of
which are noisy so the first thing I
want to do is something that tammer
talked about which is I want to put
confidence in to my network so all right
so so now i should say that um these are
slides that were made by among fake cow
who's the first author on both these
paper my graduate student and he does
like calligraphy as a hobby and he's
like much better at making pretty slides
than I am so so the quality of the
graphics of the slides all right so we
have some data quality issues that you
could have false positives and false
negatives as we discussed and in bio
grid they don't give you a confidence so
we had to assign one we did the simplest
thing that get er it all suggested which
is where we just classified evidence as
high throughput and low throughput and
then we came up with a score based on
how many publications supported the
interaction so this is not based on the
data this is just based on the number of
publications and bio grid and that gives
you some kind of thing yes so AC maybe
is supported by one publication with
high throughput techniques a B is plus
supportive on vacation with high
throughput techniques bc maybe with one
publication with high throughput
techniques CD with one publication with
low throughput techniques and so forth
be with two publications was high
completely leaks gives me some kind of
weights on the edges and all I do is I
rescale these probabilities so that they
add to one and become probabilities out
of a node and now I just walk my network
using those probabilities can be easier
call it C DST not nothing different in
the algorithm nothing different in the
computation of the matrix just using
weights on the edges
and the other thing that I'm very
interested in is incorporating known
biological knowledge into my network as
well so biologists know a lot about
pathways sets of nodes that somehow work
in concert and the other thing I'm
interested in which is worth still work
in progress is how to talk about
important nodes in the network um so how
can we incorporate pathway edges one
thing we could do is just say well these
are well curated edges let's just bump
their probabilities way up and put them
in naively as high probability edges and
do what we did before well that's
missing crucial relationships between
the paths right we actually know that in
this graph and see Denis is special
where is a to see the e doesn't mean
anything and yet if I just put the edges
together there's nothing that
distinguishes a CD from a CD so what am
I going to do um instead let's do that
but at the same time let's put the path
away is also in as duplicate nodes as in
their coherent holes and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to have two
parameters that talk about when I walk
on their basic network and when I walk
instead on the pathways and you could
think of these pathways as kind of
controlled-access highways in the grass
right if I take the freeway I could get
somewhere quicker so there are now
multiple ways there's my graduate
student mug thing he's in a purple car
he wants to get from A to C he could go
that way he could go this way or he
could take the highway okay and those
jaw that does is just adjust the
probabilities on the underlying network
notice that this kind of adjustment is
independent of DST I've changed just the
probabilities of the entire underlying
like words so if you are interested in
this R is
istence distance well you're interested
in some other measure or metric in the
network you can sort of play the same
game and do that on your distance as
well okay and then I just aggregate the
probabilities and come up with a giant
probability for the pathways I call that
captious and again i'm going to do cross
validation I'm also going to do it on
bio grid with these probabilities but
I'm also going to look at the string
network and the string network comes
with probabilistic values for each of
the edges that I'm just going to use
them what string gives me and let's just
look at the majority vote weighted
majority vote methods because again
that's what did best um previously um we
have results on the other methods as
well these are our previous results just
reminding you on mips on the first level
second level and third level this was
original majority vote versus DSD
majority vote when i add confidence
that's the light blue thing all the
probabilities go up again then when I
tell it the pathway edges are
particularly confident confidence goes
up a little bit more and if I play this
control access highway trick things go
up in confidence a little bit more but
not
um so and the highway trick I should say
ads in this scenario but in the more
global methods like global multi-cut and
functional flow it actually degrades
performance so the highway trick doesn't
work as well in those methods because
there's um and let me just summarize oh
and these are the string level results
and and look at this you got all the way
up the weight a majority vote with um
these confident pathways is up to 71
percent accuracy audience which is
really quite surprising if you know this
thing um and then straying it was even
more important to use confidence on the
edges which should surprise nobody
okay so time okay we have shown the new
metrics help incorporating confidence
always and in pathways in which case
helped even more our network so
naturally directed we don't know how
adding directions might help us that's a
interesting question we did some limited
things with known directed edges and
there just weren't enough edges that
where directors were known to matter but
if we had a way to infer direction we
might be able to do something with that
and the open question is how to find the
right metric for other metric problems
and okay I have to thank everybody um ok
so here are the collaborators on the
original paper this is um van Hess Scott
um this is actually Donna salonas PhD
student Jesus to park this is Marco Vela
bu says mcfay cow was first author how
saying another author knoweth daniels
who was my PhD student is now post
docking at bonnie burgers lab and just
as just some more people including some
undergraduates who are on the second
paper and found us alone arm in others
like a weenie simple question when
including them till yeah so just a quick
question you never looked at a final
time this is a hitting time formulation
so so not commute time but you can
rephrase a lot of what we're doing in
terms of hitting time I did not show
that today it's not exactly the same
right now we're looking at something
that I can show you offline called the
exit frequency distance and it is it can
be definitely formulated in terms of
some hitting tonight I ran out of time
before I was able to talk about life see
that yeah happy but it's nothing to do
with a community sure you commute time
is a different way to scimitar eyes the
random walk and it doesn't look like
this so in terms of saying the label of
the top-k neighbors what was your final
choice okay so three result we reported
results in the paper for k equals 10
however the results from between k
equals 10 and KO goes 20 basically
didn't change you can imagine no right
it must fit about yes so I wonder if
there's an improvement you could get by
somehow adding an optimization to choose
that k based on some never properly so
that they also have it scale by degree
or something something like that yeah
cubby we didn't try it that's a great
idea can you say anything about the
convergence way
I not as a function of K um o Isis
function of backing I'm sorry there to
case somehow I thought was my mistake
yes yes you can you we know a little bit
about the convergence rate one thing I
do know is making it a lazy random walk
where you alive where you're put in some
restart probability is going to speed
the convergence because this there too
that there are two ways to look at this
in one way letting the random walk
restart is more natural and the other
way this is more natural but if you let
the random walk we start I think
convergence speeds up faster we'll take
the rest of the questions over lunch so
thank you